so thanks everyone being here this is
our first Meetup of the year and we're
just starting to get back into the
groove of these postpen or transitional
pandemic or something to the pandemic
meetups hopefully towards the tail end
of it but I don't know so it's good to
have everyone here and everyone who's
watching virtually uh good to have you
folks here too so um everyone is excited
to see everybody it's good to have
people in a room again it's been a long
time since we've had people in a room
for one of these meetups
so the first thing we always like to do
at these meetups the very first question
I ask is who is hiring so if you're
hiring raise your hand
all right two of you are hiring so stand
up and tell everyone what you're hiring
for what company you work for and what
you want people to do
Solutions
um we report we're a financial
technology company we report on asset
that securizations we're hiring for
senior front end and back-end engineers
and in the r space we're hiring for a
Securities agency analyst with financial
with securitized products experience so
someone with some
Finance industry background and some of
the legal working on
all right so if you focus if the people
in the room if you want to find them
after they meet up go up and say Hi also
on this goes to the virtual people but
also you and you in a second
um go to the NY hack our slack and post
your job in there because people heard
you gave the talk but maybe online might
be a little hard to heard so make sure
you post it on the job postings in my
hack our slack epec you were trying to
hire too
I'll give you the Mexicans you're right
next to me
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
expertise in a distributed lag models as
well as various functional data analytic
methods so if you are one of those
people or you know someone I also have a
posting online thing so if you were to
look up like search for accounts
yes all right so for those of you on
video if you couldn't hear that because
you're not the two people with the jobs
didn't have microphones on that's dv01
dv01
dv01 is hiring and mount sinai's hiring
and hopefully post on the Mi hack are
slack and you can find it there I myself
am hiring at land analytics for a
account executive position as well as
data scientist Linux Linux Engineers
whole swath of things if you're in
person say hi to me if you're virtual
you know how to find me through the
Meetup or all the other channels to find
me
aim without tiring last chance
and people virtually Post in the post
and slack all right next up
those of you who've been coming here in
the past know that we are obsessed with
pizza at this Meetup so Today's Pizza is
from Prince Street Pizza
so please get out your phones
folks virtual I'm sorry you can't do
this hopefully you have pizza actually
one thing we do virtually is tell us
where you got virtual pizza from wait
tell us where you got real food from in
the virtual Channel people here go to
your phones bit dot Lee slash Pizza pull
those of you that know me know we've had
this pizza pole going for like 10 years
we've been collecting data for 10 years
about the different pizza places we
ordered from we do it from all around
the city well within a delivery radius
of where we're hosting the Meetup and
we're very excited to do this again so
remember Prince Street Pizza today if
you go to bit.lee Pizza pull all
lowercase don't do camel case camel case
takes you to some magazine
lowercase takes you to our pizza pole
and you can go rate the pizza on
essentially a five point scale this very
scientific data there's actually been
paintings made of this Thomas Levine
made a painting of this so you made like
a bar chart a painting of a bar chart
faceted over time
it was really cool there's actually a
live data visualization at nyhacker.org
speaking of which nyhacker.org if you
want to learn more about the Meetup go
there if you want to see 13 years worth
of videos well 13 years worth of
slideshows nine years worth of videos go
to my hackcard.org we have all the
videos up there
so before I make um the rest of the
announcements I just like to thank
brainstation for hosting us
and they'd like to say a few words
hi everyone my name is Melissa so
welcome to brain Station New York as our
wonderful Soho campus that you're seated
in this is our Soho Room because the
Amazing Brick that we have over here it
says Soho we uncovered it when we were
doing construction and decided to leave
it so a little bit about us we are a
digital Learning Company we specialize
in teaching digital skills across the
digital learning life cycle so software
engineering data science data analytics
product management digital marketing all
of these different types of skilled
skills we've empowered over a hundred
thousand professionals thus far and we
operate on a global scale with campuses
in Vancouver Toronto Miami and London
so big thing for us is we have these
boot camps they are three month
intensive programs and they're really
designed to empower those individuals
and organizations for digital success so
it's an accelerated transition into a
career in data science software
engineering or ux design it's full-time
um nine to five every day during the
week we also have part-time boot camps
so anyone who is not willing to kind of
get up and quit their job for this type
of career change can also work that way
as well
so this is our talent Network one really
great thing that we do in brainstation
is we have a post boot camp boot camp
because we know that people take our
boot camps to change their career to
really jump into this Tech space so it's
super beneficial that after a student
graduates from the boot camp we connect
them with with this amazing talent
Network we have connections at Deloitte
Google Capital One like really household
names that we can bring Recruiters in
from
we also have some amazing scholarships
available so uh we did offer a New York
openstat a scholarship program to our
current boot camp running January 24th
and then uh we also have these amazing
scholarship programs for our part-time
courses that happen throughout the week
so you might have run into a few
students coming in we have a project
management course running right now and
a few other courses kicking off later in
the year
so yeah that is it from us if you want
more information about us please check
out our website we have a courses
bootcamps kicking off all the time and
uh we're always looking for new faces on
campus so welcome and thanks so much so
folks there's a few other events coming
up in the next few months that we'd like
to make everyone aware of just in the
community you'll be getting some
emailings about this at discount codes
there is a Tampa data science conference
the D4 conference coming up in April
you'll get a discount code for that
coming up if people want to go to Tampa
there's also a virtual program a virtual
option for that so check out your emails
coming for that soon there is a data
Council conference coming up in I think
March in Austin
uh it's another good group we like them
a lot and our finance will be in May if
you're into finance and the New York R
conference will be in July more details
coming soon for that in fact um we've
had a few speakers from that conference
here I know some of you have attended
it's a great conference really love it
speaking of conferences the our gov
conference was back in December and the
videos are now up at rstats.ai there's
also a recap available I think at Lander
analytics I think the recap available if
you came and got one of these awesome
t-shirts that I'm wearing because all of
our conference t-shirts mix up like my
entire wardrobe now I have like a
different color for all of them like
five colors for each that's great
uh but check that out if you want to
check out the videos rstats.ai there's
like seven or eight years I can't keep
track eight years of New York r videos
there are four years of our gov videos
so there's a lot of stuff up there a lot
of great content in addition to the
videos you'll find at nyhacker.org
today is possibly a special milestone
for the Meetup we're not quite sure it
might be the 150th Meetup
the reason we're not quite sure is
because technically in the Manifest it's
151st but one of those was a holiday
party so that doesn't necessarily count
one of them was just hanging out at the
bar with a statistician who was in town
does that count as a Meetup so today's
either 149th 150 or 151st Meetup
printable thank you so given that we're
inside the confidence interval we can
conclude that this is a
we've been going since 2009 so it's
really exciting that we've hit this
Milestone all these meetups so thank you
everyone for being here it's really
exciting to hit this Milestone together
and again you can find all this stuff I
think
[Applause]
hopefully we'll keep going more and more
if all you folks in the room now
next few months
we need a speaker for February which is
next month right
if anyone wants to be a speaker either
in person or from the virtual land let
me know we're also going to randomly
call on people Carlin to give us to give
a talk next month but seriously we need
a speaker for next month we don't have
one lined up yet so if anyone wants to
give the talk and Carlin doesn't doesn't
able to
um uh let me know because we like having
these things every month we don't like
to miss a month so we haven't missed a
month in like 12 years so hook us up
folks
March we do have lined up we have a
speaker ready for March uh we don't have
a date yet but we do have a speaker
lineup for March but April May June
going forward we have some open slots so
if you'd like to give a talk or you
think maybe you'd like to give a talk
you need convincing say hi to me say hi
to Nicole say hi to anyone who spoke
with these meetups before I think you'll
see it's a friendly crowd as everyone's
room is and everyone virtually is
friendly well I don't know all you
virtually I don't know who's there
hopefully you're all friendly
so please say hi to give a talk
so before I bring up our speaker for
this month
she is doing a Herculean effort she is
badly injured but she's here to talk to
us so it was all just being super
excited that you're pulling through for
us so thank you so much for doing this
please welcome Epic
[Applause]
okay hello everyone good evening thank
you for coming out I'm very excited to
be the first Speaker of
2023 of the Meetup series and also the
speaker of the 150th
Meetup let's just assume it's 150th good
good confidence interval so before I
begin a few disclosures I have no
Financial or other conflicts of interest
associated with the talk that I will be
giving today I am funded my work is
funded by an r01 Grant from the National
Institute of Health and as well the
house of platter Institute of
they're so Health at Mount Sinai the
study and the data that I'll be
discussing tonight come from a seed
pilot seed grant that was funded by the
Columbia University data Science
Institute which is where I was up until
last summer
um
and the last disclosure I'll make before
I continue is I um I'm suffering for
well I shouldn't say suffer I um I'm
trying to be more positive I have a
herniated disc and nerve damage in my
back so if I make if I make a funny face
during my talk it is not you it is me
apologies in advance okay and now with
that disclosure
back to regular programming okay
so I am an assistant professor at um as
I said at the house of planners soon for
digital Health at Mount Sinai and as
well the I can't School of Medicine
there and my research revolves around
this idea of best best practices for
integrating the various fast expanding
or advancing mobile Health Technologies
and various machine learning methods to
patient-generated Health Data towards
elucidating some of the currently open
research questions in the field of
women's reproductive health for example
endometriosis and as well questions that
pertain to Patient populations that are
at increased risk for various Health
disparities for example sexual and
gender minority adults
now one of these um these two patient
populations that I mentioned have some
common features to them both from the
clinical perspective and as well the
data perspective from the patients or
the clinical perspective
these individuals tend to be less likely
to seek Healthcare or less
they are harder to reach in in clinical
settings so either they're less likely
to seek Health Care actively due to a
variety of reasons or they they have
their access is somehow impaired so
they're less likely to have access to
proper adequate health care right again
due to various reasons and as well we
see that in the
both their health status and as well
potential social determinants of their
health and disease status tend to be
less well documented and standard
clinical documentation so for example
the electronic hot records from the more
data perspective there tends to be less
already collected data
available for secondary research for
example and this pertains to both the
granularity and the quality of the data
and as a consequence of all these
factors there tends to be there's less a
priority knowledge a much smaller body
of literature than there would be
otherwise which of course is required
for us to generate hypotheses which are
required for us to conduct a formal
scientific method informed research
so in these scenarios
the direct patient input or direct input
from the individual in the particular
context is particularly useful because
it can augment our understanding of the
patient's health status give us a more
comprehensive profile of their
um we would have their standing and as
well monitor their response to various
treatments for example and this drug
input can come from
wearables and sensors so it can be
passively collected data and as well it
could be actively contributed patient
contributed data right
and as well Nicole I'm including
ecological monetary assessments here as
well so these are research prompts you
send a prompt to collect data versus
they
track whenever they choose to and when
and these techniques are particularly
powerful when we combine them with the
appropriate
um statistical or I guess data science
now that's the term we should be using
to be cool
various techniques
so as to give us a even better glimpse
into their health status and this of
course would combined with the with the
all of these techniques together that
some of the things that we can get at
that we can otherwise with at this level
of beta granularity is to look at
trajectories not just over time at the
group level but also look at things at
the individual level right small data
issues like at do person level modeling
or personal level prediction
recommendations which is now of course
one of the hottest topics
and get a little bit more Technical and
do comparisons and
assess at what level we really should be
tailoring or in what context these
individual versus group or subgroup
level techniques
are actually useful or necessary or not
necessary right as we'll see in some
scenarios
now when you are dealing with these
patient populations when you don't have
enough already collected data
um
what can you do while you conduct your
own exploratory pilot study as a
starting point so that's what we did
with my colleagues
we aim to
we we I'm going to give you an example
using this personally completed study of
ours that focus on sexual and gender
minor adults and looking at their memos
or health metrics and I thought given
that this is the art community and some
of the varying
and Trust areas
I thought this was a good case Center a
good good story to share partly because
I think pilot studies are a lot less
discussed but paradoxically they are if
a commonality in especially in clinical
settings there are reality we we have to
do them for many reasons not least of
which is that we are required to do them
to inform the design of our big future
study that we submit to NIH to seek
funding and then if we have good you
know estimates and effect sizes then we
can apply for bigger grants and you know
that's that's the most important thing
if you're in Academia if there are any
academics you know what I'm talking
about but maybe not looking at your
faces maybe no academics it's okay so if
you're so you can you should feel good
good maybe good about your yourself you
don't have to deal with this um but
anyhow in case there's someone from NIH
watching um I'll just move on okay so
let me uh motivate the premise and the
study background as I alluded to earlier
the goal of the the study was to
investigate ammo through Health metrics
among sexual and gender minor adults and
we specifically focused on black and
latinx sexual and gender minor adults so
this is a multiple stigmatized
population because they belong in two
minority groups
um so and the premise was centered
around the minor distress model
framework this is an imperial
evidence-based framework that postulates
that
environmental stress or individualized
minority individuals who are chronically
exposed to various environmental social
stressors are more likely to experience
various impairments in both
psychological and physiological Health
outcomes so and this is caused by
both the not just the psychological
stress that it imposes on them but as
well the
the force adaptation that they have to
go through somehow they have to adjust
you know go about their days function in
some ways but then it does distress
um inducer isn't going away even if they
are masking whatever however it is
required from them so it's
it results in a whole host of adverse or
unpleasant Health outcomes so that's the
general framework and this framework as
you might imagine has many determinants
many many factors go into measuring this
if you wanted to measure the whole or
kind of evaluate this whole home up okay
and as a part of this model the argument
is that these stressors are unique to
these individuals right so it's not
experienced by non-stigmatized
individuals that the theory suggests
that it is chronic and it is socially
based so there are many things in in the
individual's environment that could be
contributing to these outcomes
Okay so
um given the the
I guess the theme of the night and this
is an art community I'll be taking a
data
lens and the questions that I'll be
investigating investigating will focus
on the data related aspects of the study
specifically so we'll get a little
deeper dive into it but the of
but the overall study also had some
clinical questions and I'm happy to talk
about those afterwards if if you are
interested of course okay so the you
know we aim to collect because it's an
expert or study and because there are a
lot of unknowns and as a starting point
we wanted to collect a wide range of
data
we aim to collect ecological monetary
assessments and as well object Louis
estimated data that are related to that
we thought that we theorized were
related to the minority stressor model
um among black and latinx sexual and
gender minor adults and some of the
questions that we asked that were
specifically related to the data and the
to be able to answer our questions was
are these relationships so the exposure
to the the various stressor and the
outcome are these relationships stable
over time within an individual right
like within person variably and as well
what is the magnitude if any between
individuals so it does one person
experience this or the outcome or the
exposure
similar to the other individuals in this
in this sample
just a very brief just to describe the
standard sample we ended up that we had
43 individuals of sexual and gender
minority individuals of color we had the
median age was pretty young at 27. we
have an okay range 19 to 57 but of
course you might say we don't have you
know all older adults which is fair
on half about half are full-time
employed and we have a pretty good good
mix of
other other demographic factors as well
okay now let's get a little bit deeper
into the data structure so we have a
hierarchical data structure and we have
data coming from multiple streams we
have first Baseline measures apologies
for the typos so these are the trait
measures like lifetime exposure to
discrimination experiences
depressive clinical depressive
symptomology anxiety but again lifetime
asking them about their you know past
life or the past several years and so
forth right but these were measured only
once then we have the day level measures
of again depressive and anxiety
symptomology have you experienced any
discrimination related
incidences today any answers we also ask
them about anticipated so how much did
you do you anticipate today or did you
anticipate today and other things that
are other outcomes or other measures
that have been indicated to be
associated with this population
specifically so like there could be
internalized stigma and so forth which
have been indicated in the literature to
be associated with for example
um impaired sleep health
and then we have at the even more
granular level we have continuous
measures so we have we had them wear
response trackers fitbits specifically
to collect physical activity and sleep
data
we had individuals provide data for up
to 30 days
um every day and also wear the trackers
for 30 days so we have data uh up well a
little over 30 days for some really
really eager participants but of course
given the nature of the study we have we
have some missingness which is is beyond
the it's it's another maybe maybe for
February but I can we can talk about
missing bit but anyhow I won't get into
the missingness okay so as the data lead
on the study I am really concerned my
major concerns are are twofold with
respect to the data I want to maximize
the data that I already have I I already
have a small sample right I only have 43
individuals compared to millions of
patients you get from electronic cap
records for example which has its own
host of problems
or questions and things that you need to
consider so in this case I want to
maximize the data that I have but what I
have where I don't have strength in
numbers of participants I have have
strength in the the temporality of the
data because not only do I have 30 days
and in some cases twice a day data on
some of these measures I have continuous
physical activity and sleep data and
given that this prospective study and
given that we had phenomenal
coordinators if I say so myself even if
the data were missing we had a pretty
good sense of why it was missing in most
cases with of course with a few
exceptions so I wonder if possible
specifically for the the wearable data I
want to be able to look at trajectories
and I do not want to collapse into a
scalar so what is typically done when
you have right like if you've read any
studies that have physical activity as
an outcome they look at their level
summaries or weak level summaries I said
I don't want to do that I want to be
able to use entire days data if possible
as the unit of analysis now my second
concern is I want to understand the
extent of variability that occur that
occurs Within
within versus between individuals and
why is this important
um because it has various Downstream
implications for example if you want to
design an intervention you want to know
before you jump into let's do a
personalized in their jobs interaction
the first thing you should ask is well
do we need actually individualization or
tailoring right and if yes at what level
sometimes you only you don't need person
level tailoring sometimes you can get
away with subgroup tailoring it like if
you have a heterogeneous disease you
could do SUB disease level or phenotype
level tailoring sometimes that is what
is necessary so I want to know the love
of precision that I need I also want to
know would identify the time variant
versus person dependent variables
because again that'll inform what kind
of intervention I should I should be
designing for a given individual and
what time points it could vary and it
could also given that this an experts or
exploratory study
I did also reveal
um tell us and given the wide range of
data that we're collecting ultimately we
want parsimony I want to get the most
bang for my buck so I want to know
which of these variables have the
highest predictive values so that in a
in a subsequent study I can focus on
those variables and not so much the
others right if it's if they are time in
um
Coast cost intensive then maybe I can I
can forego those
so when we say variability this is of
course not a novel
um normal term this is very common the
estimated Quantified talked about
but but essential and there are various
different terminology in in the field
but ultimately the
the essence of it is looking at the
components of variability and that the
hierarchical decomposition of variance
in whatever outcome of interest you have
if you have heard I'm sure many of you
have heard of intra class correlation
which is it's the proportion of the
within versus between group source of
variance again very very common and an
old old term and in R of course we have
the mix level modeling framework which
is a great powerful framework that where
you can extract the random effect
variances and then you can vary nicely
and easily get the group level versus
within
individual variances so that's um that's
very easy to do you might have heard
this is also called sometimes it's
called the repeatability because it also
allows you to evaluate the reliability
or stability of a measurement so if
that's a concern to you you know how
stable a measure is over time you can
also use the same framework to get at it
um now while and of course for the for
mlms we have the lme4 Elmer tester lots
of many many many libraries in art that
does it they're great um I use them
every day all the time so if any of you
have been involved in their development
thank you
um
now what is a little because sometimes
not so easy is to quantify the
uncertainty and estimates just by
extracting these random effect variances
and thanks to Google I found out about
it has been a while since I found out
but anyhow I still Googled to find out
there's this rbtr library is it I don't
know if it's pronounced repeater repeat
R repeater I don't know but there is
this Library which is wonderful it's
built on the the lme4 actually library
and it allows you to run a likelihood
ratio test and give you um quantifies
the answer if you need in estimates
so that's really nice so if you're
publishing and if you need P values and
if you need you know the test that you
can write about
this you can do that through this
Library so it's it's great
okay so using um again let's I'm trying
to prove give a I guess feeling of code
live coding so pretend that we're live
coding these that's why I put these the
codes
um I I know you all know what the linear
mix model fit output looks like so you
can ignore if you want but the point
being when using the rptr library you
can do the repeatable estimation and I'm
using here now I I provided examples
from two different hierarchies of data
one I have the depressive scores daily
depressive symptoms that we collected
with the EMA data from the participants
that's the phq4 scores
and then on the right I have
um I have step counts so these are
yeah so these are the step Counts from
from the Fitbit now the main thing to
really notice from this is that for the
for the depressive scores about 33 of
the variation is due so between
individual four pers um due to person
level factors
um so that that's quite a bit of
variability whereas First Steps it's
actually very very small even to have a
specifically significance it was very
small which I am not surprised
um to be honest because there are a lot
of factors that go into someone's
activity pattern mind you the the step
counts the day level or the hourly sub
counts you get from the Fitbit don't
tell you whether it's Leisure or
whatever like what is the what type of
physical activator so it's um of course
there's going to be a lot of other
residual variants that's involved
no but you might say you know these
visuals are nice but I want something
more visual visual well again I
credit goes to Tristan Mark I have not
met Tristan Marr is have any of you met
Justin Mark Tristan Marr has this
wonderful blog where he puts his R codes
on various techniques and here I found I
used his codes to generate these plots
these plots are plot the same data as
the phq scores here that you're seeing
as a summary this is from each
individual so I faceted the the daily
phq the depressive scores from each
individual and what you're looking at is
what happens with different
considerations of the the pulling of the
variances right so if I assume that
these are all completely independent so
there is no pooling where the model is
blind to every other individual's data
versus if I ignore the nested the
hierarchical structure of the data and
if I just assume that the data come from
the same individual or everybody is
identical to each other versus there's
partial pooling so I I have the the
mixed level model where I have
um I'm including
both fixed and random effects so you um
based on the amount of data you have per
person you're seeing the lines overlap
so if you have more information from the
person they're going to be closer when
you have fewer data points they're going
to be further apart so the and what
happens is model pools there's more
pooling have more shrinkage the more
pulling happening of the individuals who
are further away right from from the
average but you might say well this is
these are a lot of black dots it's 7 P.M
I don't want to have to spend more brain
energy on this I and I completely
empathize because when I made these plus
it was
an early hour of the day and of course
we all have better focus so here is a
better plot of the exact same thing now
this is a topographic map and thank You
Tristan who also thought of this
potential problem now you're looking at
the distance between the the pooling and
the the average effect versus the no
pulled and again the the outlier so to
speak the ones who are further away are
the people
um who had fewer data points or in other
words the ones who did not adhere to the
study protocol as well so maybe they
drop out I don't know but anyhow those
are that's the you know that was the
that's basically what's happening
foreign
now about you might and I know this
because I watched previous art talks I
know
um
a lot of you like Bayesian methods right
right so Jared might have been thinking
Wellness I mean lme is nice but you know
there is also brms the The Bays salad
the r stand arm and you might even say
epec you took the stand arm Workshop in
2020 April you should be using whereas
your r stand file and since I took the
workshop I'm now an expert in in our
stand and base of course of course I did
not have to Google for this well I also
made you a Bayesian answer so this is
again thank You Tristan Mark I wish we
could find this for somewhere I'm really
grateful
um so again I follow while I did look at
my workshop codes a little bit for this
so you know that thank you and I still
have the book that was that was that's
also wonderful anyhow so you can also do
amazing um again I'm plotting the same
same data but what I'm now do doing is
instead of one line per person I have a
whole distribution I have 40 4 000 lines
now I have a distribution per person and
what the the whole again thing that we
can see from the main point we can see
from the the slattus chart is that the
the individuals that have the larger
blob are the ones with the larger
uncertainty right so the so the model is
having a much harder time estimating
those individuals versus the ones who
had a lot more data so those are their
confidence bounds are a lot tighter
so yeah so if you're a Bayesian person
this would be the figure to look at and
you can ignore the previous speakers so
and everybody is happy now
um and again this is I guess the side
point is
you know data points matters the
temporal data really matters
and if you do EHR research I mean I we
can grab a drink afterwards and and you
know commiserate about the data point
but that's again maybe February topic
okay so now you might be thinking well
what about you in fact you also
mentioned that you have the data from
the the fitbits
um and you were you made a big deal
about the right the scalar versus the
trajectory data analysis
so we can also look at the temporal
fluctuations at the more granular levels
and then we can include not just the the
right the person level the days but then
we can also put in hours of data for
example so now you have
um or you can you can work with
three-dimensional data fuel or arrays or
data cubes don't you can Google it but I
just made up data cubes I don't know if
it's an actual term it's not from
tristum so you can blame me if that
makes no sense that's my fault okay so
let's consider now the the
three-dimensional data scenario and I'll
use physical activity from the risk worn
trackers as as the as the example and
very
um yeah we I mean definitely I'm happy
to talk more if needed
um
but a two sentence I guess background
motivating
Summary of why study physical acting and
sanitary Behavior because it's a major
public health concern It's associated
with a long range of Health outcomes and
it's
both it's adverse Health outcomes and as
well as its lack of it is more prevalent
in
um
the patient population these more at
risk patient populations and both
patient populations that I mentioned in
the beginning of my talk so that that
would be important to keep in mind and
in terms of looking at the the
temporality of the activity we are not
there more recently there has been a lot
more focus on Distributing your activity
so many of you probably already seen the
National Health guidelines on you know
like three times a week of 150 minutes
of activity or this much steps whatever
like 7 000 or 10 000 steps these
arbitrary numbers what we're not finding
out is that it is actually just as if
not more important to distribute your
activity throughout the day so for
example if you're going to the gym in
the morning running your heart out for
an hour but then if you're sitting for
the next 16 hours you're erasing the
health effects that you're occurring in
the morning so now the guidelines are
shifting to you know stand up every hour
or you know walk throughout the day and
so forth so that would be the other
rationale for focusing on the on the
timing or the pattern of the activity
now in this again keeping in mind the
the pilot context of the study the the
main question that the first question
that pops up oftentimes is are there
different profiles of physical activity
trajectories among these individuals
right before making any inferential or
trying to test any other inference
social I guess questions or
relationships and if there are different
patterns in what ways they differ right
because maybe they don't differ maybe
everybody has the same pattern of
activity I mean it could be right and in
this case again I want my unit of
analysis I don't want every my physical
activity I don't want scalar data points
I want to close search trajectory data
so I want the entire data curve so the
curve of both 30 days but also 24 hour
24 data points to be the whole unit of
analysis so in my model I want that to
be entered as a single data point I
don't want discrete 30 times 24 you know
whatever I don't want to do that okay
that that because those model has
different underlying assumptions okay so
what what do we do well the functional
data framework to the rescue the the
functional data and now in what makes
functional data analysis unique is that
the collection of each unit of analysis
is a collection of discrete observations
so you have data curves and what you do
is that you take the the curve of data
points and before you put it into a
model or you analyze you create basis
functions you smooth and synthesize the
general trend from all of these discrete
or really Wiggly lined then I want to
find
at a trend the general Trend that you
feel confident
that it represents the
um the data points then you do your
regression or whatever modeling you want
to do so in this case I want to do
functional clustering in a previous talk
I had talked about the fund fan package
where it's a probabilistic functional
clustering method in fact I talked about
this at the New York art Conference in
June so this is a really nice follow-up
this is episode two I guess so that was
in and one thing I said in that talk and
it is true that's why I said it one
limitation was that it did not allow you
to Cluster
um repeated when you have repeated or
nested data sets so if you have repeated
measures from an individual you couldn't
enter that you had to get a person level
average right and then it would it would
cluster well
um they run at all I think I ruined that
last name so I apologize but the the
same authors
had created fun lbm this is functional
co-clustering of latent block modeling
base clustering
and they this month this package allows
you to Cluster nested data you do not
see that coming so surprise so within
this with this package you can cluster
not just rows of data right like your
trajectories of data but also columns so
in this case days
based on our data set
even though I'm for the purpose of this
talk I'm not so interested in clustering
your days although for example if you're
studying if you want to study
seasonality that would of course be very
interesting like if you're looking at
electricity consumption across different
neighborhoods then you would want to do
seasonal like that stuff but we did not
look at electricity consumption in these
individuals
so that's I won't get into it okay so
this um maybe the model allows you to
Cluster rows and columns and you're
working with data cubes so you need to
convert your um to two sentence data
processing
um summary I'm definitely not an escape
my R file looked very embarrassing when
I was trying to convert my data set into
arrays I had to do a lot of Googling but
I managed so you need to have an array
of of individuals and then days and then
you have in in our case 24 that the
third dimension is 24 because for each
hour
and then the rest is very easy the model
takes care of it it also allows you so
the way you you
um in in these models because you're
using model fit indices like the aicbic
ETC it's all relative index so you do
need to test multiple oh my it was my
microphone not working all this time
oh okay so I guess for the sake of those
who are virtually watching we'll just
start from the beginning I guess
okay okay okay okay okay
um sounds good so anyhow so because it's
comparative fit in the Seas you do need
to test different models and the model
does allow you to test out different
ones within one single model so you
don't have to write a loop through
function which I'm really bad at you
don't want me to write a loop function
in your computer unless you want it to
crash so this is very great so I I tried
a bunch of different models with
different cluster resolutions it allows
fourier-based basis I do not get into
the details but when you're picking your
basis functions you have different
options right you can do the beat the
the most common Beast blinds if you have
periodic data you can do the Fourier
function so here are the
the default is for you I don't know why
I'm going to speculate maybe because
they were they had the seasonality in
mind maybe they thought the most user
might have free I mean I I don't know
but anyhow you can put in uh be spline
splines or Fourier different
initialization methods I played around
with with a bunch of them it's a pretty
pretty solid package and none of his my
models crashed so it survived me so you
know it was I think it was it was a good
test
um but anyway so I tested different
costs of resolutions but so clustering
both in terms of the number of
individual clusters or phenotypes if you
you know if you want to use a
terminology it's same or and as well
clustering the base right but I kept the
days at two because as I said I don't
expect this is 30 consecutive days from
each individual so I don't expect a lot
of seasonality there could be some
weekday effects but I did actually not
shown here but I did tester there was no
weekday effect so I just kept it out too
because I'm focusing on trying to
compare it individuals now again for a
purpose of giving us the live coding
experience I I put the the code input
and output there but essentially the
model suggested that the best cluster
resolution was the one where you've had
three clusters of individuals
based on the fit and relative fit
indices we had about 48 of the
individuals in one cluster about 36 so
about a third and then about 17 percent
in the third cluster of individuals
and then for the for the day clustering
it was about 35 and 65 but that's
kind of not very surprising okay so
that's a pretty pretty good distribution
so you don't want when you are doing
this type of clustering you don't want
to end that with
um clusters that are that have too few
individuals like if you only have three
people that's probably you should
probably
try different different models that's
probably not a good model unless there
is a theoretical justification for why
you would have those three outlier
individuals or a really distinct
individuals
um so again the the fun lbm package has
these nice built-in Gigi plot 2 based
plot functions that you can plot so in
the in the first one you're looking at
each individual's clusters or phenotypes
activity patterns predicted activity
patterns
based on the two different day clusters
that they had
on and on the right side it's just the
three clusters based on that they
separated by the the day cluster
foreign
so the two figures if you if you just
compare as a whole it shouldn't differ
too much but if you compare the
different colored ones the individuals
there is some difference in there some
meaningful difference in there which is
why I generated my own figures with this
here you're looking at the three and
they're just I specifically name this
phenotypes so that it's distinct from
the base so these are individuals okay
so three different
um phenotypes or clusters of individuals
based on their activity patterns we
could very very Loosely we could think
of one of them as being the really
sedentary group
the second or the second and the third
might actually look different but there
are some distinctions in there
for example the phenotype 3 the third
cluster have a more distributed pattern
of activity
even though they do seem their their
total might seem a little less than the
the second cluster
um
and they wake up a little little earlier
so the the second group is a little late
Riser and there are different and there
are further things details that you can
notice and and a lot of these things
have can have important implications for
you and in terms of what time they start
their activity what time they end for
example if if you are looking at
nighttime activity insomnia Etc people
who have for veteran reason might have
nighttime activity that would also be
relevant in this in these scenarios that
you can kind of detect those nuances
which is the range of confidence
intervals yeah
yeah okay so now putting the steps into
perspective I did different
I committed the crime that I've been
calling all along I I got um de la
waslam's just
to have
um
some sort of a I guess comparison visual
comparison you're you're looking at the
total day steps a morning during the day
and evening these are based on from the
times they woke up two times they went
to bed so it's not necessarily at the
same hour but
um from each individuals and if you
wanted to put this into further
perspective like if you wanted to
somehow compare these two thresholds or
cutoffs there are actually published
um
suggested or recommended step thresholds
that would allow you to Loosely assign
the individuals to highly active active
or low active or sanitary groups so we
can do those that would allow you to
let's say that clusters one might not be
sufficiently active for example and so
forth so you can you can again make
those distinctions right like
okay so now these are exploring are
there different clusters and in what
ways they are different and look okay so
the next step might be you might be
wondering okay now that I have these
different clusters that's great then you
made all these plots but what are some
other things questions that we can ask
um the other things we can do is once we
have these different phenotypes between
individuals or or days if that's what
you are focusing on you might be
interested in whether they are
differentially associated with these
other outcomes that we collected in the
data set that I mentioned right we had
the EMAs we had the day level data we
had the Baseline so in this case in this
example it turns out that actually
they're not explained by
the demographic factors like the things
like age gender category orientation Etc
um
as well as their traits so the Baseline
anxiety and depressive scores for
example which again I wasn't as a
kinesiologist I'm not too surprised
because there's a lot of other residual
factors that goes into explaining your
day-to-day activity but it was a good
sanity check to look at also sometimes
interesting every now and then you'll
find a significant relationship and it
turns out there's you know there's a
reason for for that Association
but and then you can look at the data
right are there certain data
associations that that differ across
these clusters
um
now what happens is let's see is this
the phone
and to sweat yes so it turns out there
are some associations some some
differences in in the
um
the Baseline the Baseline depressive
scores
um they do explain excuse me there's
there's with the Baseline there's no
difference but what happens is at the
day level so I remember I had mentioned
um we also looked at we also had them
report their anticipated discrimination
experiences for example as a part of the
the minority stress model framework it
turns out there are some differences
across these clusters
so that is one thing that you can do now
you one thing to note here and I um I I
didn't get into that is of course if you
if you do notice an effect like that
it's the the next logical step is to go
further into looking into why
because there could be other factors
that are that are impacting imposing on
or explaining this relationship so those
could be
so this would be the starting point for
further
um
probing some of those relationships
so it's in conclusion why do we do all
these data acrobatics and go through the
trouble of collecting all these
different data at different levels it's
really the the collection of data of
course that's a big big task but it's
also important as we collect an as we're
analyzing even if they are a small pilot
data from just 43 individuals that you
know we've spent a long time like native
Ram it's important to think what
techniques we're using and and whether
there could be techniques about and
Beyond what we already know that could
that we could Implement to get more out
of the data that we have and this is
particularly important if you have
already small data set that you're
you're trying to maximize and make sure
that you're analyzing correctly so that
you are not getting these potentially
not so correct inferences
um right like not not forcing just maybe
you have seen some in a literature where
you just they just force a linear model
on whatever variable they have it's just
a little like an anova or a linear my
every time so linear even though it's
not a linear relationship they just
force a linear regression I don't know
why but you know so you can
we should avoid doing doing that of
course
and the other advantage of course we can
characterize the phenotypes based on
trajectories which yields additional
information that can augment
that the patient the profile of the
patient of the individual both in terms
of not just their health status but
other day-to-day their their
unique personal environmental factors
that could again inform other things
and of course having the passive data
collection I'm always all for it not
just because I'm a kinesiologist but
it's slow burn low effort and it
provides a lot more information and in
this day and age it's so much more
easier
um and as I mentioned earlier that has
relevant for tailoring care so if you
write a few in this case we probably
don't need 43 different methods of
delivering the same intervention maybe I
can get away with just three different
intervention designed if I'm doing
something related to physical activity
for example so that you know it's okay
it doesn't have to be
that that sometimes the Precision needs
to be determined for its level
um
and in the bigger pictures coming out of
this this pilot study the the focus the
bigger picture is the data-driven
symptom self-management it's more
popular and of course it's very useful
and that's that's what I study of course
I'm biased that it's important but it's
it's a complex and interdisciplinary
issue there are a lot of questions that
goes into making these decisions and it
requires a wide range of techniques so
that that's something to consider you
know what are some of the techniques
that I have in my toolkit what are some
of the other techniques that I might
need to enrich my toolkit so that I'm
making these data driven decisions in a
more informed way and to maybe address
our blind spots in the in the more type
of way
and yeah if for those of you who are
curious where is the study going is this
it are you going to try to publish this
plots with no access labels no that's
that's not it
um I just couldn't find a way to add
Gigi plot extensions to those plots but
so there are as I mentioned we asked
some exposure clinical questions
um it one of the main things that focus
on is sleep sleep outcomes because
that's a very major public health
concern especially among sexual and
gender minority adults so we are looking
to compare personal level versus group
level predictive models in terms of
their predictive performance of course
the more personal ones will have better
prediction but we will be looking at
some of the high hyper parameters and
and so forth and looking at Which models
are best and then identify potentially
modifiable psychosocial factors so that
if you are designing we know what to
um
intervene on right which are important
because you can't intervene on factors
that you can't modify that's I guess a
lot of money spent on a not very good
way okay so with that I'd like to thank
you and these are my collaborators
um and there are many more but these are
as many as that fit you can contact me
and connect with me through there I
don't know why I don't have my links in
but you can look me up I also brought
some cards so feel free to pick one and
and with that I feel like I'm happy to
take any questions
[Applause]
to type the 3d effect is really very
striking I mean subject to the people
even come into a room together
at the same time and sit down and see
that they're slacking off and then
throwing up yeah and but you found no
you found no correlations have you
thought about looking in like their
medical records and trying to find
another way of identifying as many types
without actually looking at the steps so
there are patterns of course are
statistically distinct that's um that
would be like as a consequence of the
the clustering so they are they do have
different patterns and that in and of
itself depending on the clinical context
is important so as I said like if you
are interested in doing a sedentary
behavior intervention you know that
cluster one is really important to focus
on because not only do they have a
narrow bound of activity but it's also
way below the threshold of what has been
established to be you know the minimally
required amount
in terms of the timing you might say for
example while the the second group they
are
they're kind of inactive in a day like
if you know that they wake up but then
they're Senator early and they maybe you
might say okay like I'm going to do a
Jedi just-in-time intervention and in my
Jedi I'm going to deliver the prompt in
the morning to these individuals whereas
for the third group you might say well
they seem to have a slump in the middle
of the day in the afternoon let's say
they're in the office and they're sleepy
and they take a nap or whatever you can
say okay I'm going to deliver my prompt
in this Jedi for these individuals and
maybe I'll wake them or something or
like tell them go have some coffee and
take a walk around a vlog or something
so that would that in and of itself is
informative in terms of looking the the
association the I did find um there was
an association between the patterns and
anticipated discrimination I I can
cautiously talk about it but I want to
be very cautious and not you know make
any um
genetics so it could be it could be or
at the very you know if we wanted to be
keep it
age was not associated but it could be
like if you adjust it for some of the
other factors could be my sense is that
that might have to do with what they're
doing that day like if they're at work
if if I already have that assumption if
let's say
if that's something that I experience if
I'm going to work that day or if I'm
going to going outside a place where I
would anticipate that discrimination
then of course like I'm going to be more
active that they were as if I'm staying
home
that I wouldn't anticipate that right
that discrimination experience and I'm
also I'm home so I'm more I'm less
active so that could be a third right
intervening variable so that could be it
so that would be something to further
probe how many days of observation you
need to identify what human type of
person is
the minimally required um
that would be let's see did I do a
predictive I remember using the refund
package which is another functional data
I don't know if you're from another FDA
package I did do some predictions but
I'm trying to remember how what was the
minimally required
I had a large not for these guys because
it's just 43 but I remember that if you
wanted to do information pooling I.E if
you wanted to somehow use information
from one person to be able to predict
the other I had a sample of 120 the
that's the work I presented back in June
um
I know I was able to do pretty decent
predictions with that one for these I
would just keep it if I were doing the
test train you know validate framework I
would just keep it within person so I
would maybe say if I only have two weeks
of data can I predict the next two weeks
but there are some on the EMA in the EMA
literature there is some evidence some
studies demonstrate that you for example
only need two weeks of data to be able
to predict
um the the next like subsequent base
oh no I mean 14 days is not bad it's um
if you're doing prospective data
collection and if you have a dedicated
coordinator and if you really maximize
um if you're you know if you have a team
of people who who have experience with
this it's a goal
if you get um eager people they are
again like these are populations that
tend to be already eager to do like
especially um for example I as I said I
do women's health research
and especially patients with
endometriosis they already self-monitor
so they are very eager and they provide
a lot of data but for the general like
if in your scenario
but no these are not not by a bank
people
um I think
with respect to things like physical
activity people to unless there's a
major change in their you know life
events
their patterns tend to be pretty
habitual like it doesn't change you know
unless there's a covid and then another
covet and then their activity but but
besides those
um instances they tend to be pretty
steady in there even with I didn't get
into it but um
a lot of the psychological measures like
day to day they were also pretty
consistent there were a few people where
it like widely varied
there is um
there is this argument the the saying
with in the psychometrics literature
each individual has their own style of
using a scale so given let's say the Vas
their their mental
um perception of what is a zero score of
zero and a score of 100 which are the
minimum Max on a Vigilant scale like
they actually have their like that
perception the first so my score of zero
is different than your score of zero and
you you can see that actually if you
have a large enough sample like you'll
have you'll always have that those few
outlier participants who just just give
a score of three whatever the
circumstance you just score of three
it's a score of three they're just Adam
and any of course that like ruins your
your data sample but that's another
question it's a problem but you know
that's um so that you're going to get
that kind of variability but if you're
keeping it within person they tend to be
pretty pretty consistent so with minimum
I think it would depend on the variable
but if you're looking at physical
activity that should be pretty pretty
stable like if I have a few days of
weekdays and a few like weekend days and
then they'll collect data on like
especially like Christmas day so forth
then they they should be pretty steady
a question back to maybe your might want
to switch back to the slide with three
phenotypes they punch together of like
activities
um
is those phenotypes of like a
representative
fictional person across the small
results or is it represented across the
the groupings so these are observed so
these are observed observed steps per
phenotype per group here so I guess one
question they might have is how does you
know one individual look compared to
that for when you're trying to do
just-in-time intervention
you're going to want to see like a
significant outlier but someone might
just have an outline because I have to
be on a plate I don't want to be annoyed
by notifications that I'm sitting on a
plane for the next eight hours
there's times when you need to
appropriately have intervention and
other times where it's like
counterproductive yeah
ways to pull Cycles out or is that still
yeah I'll go challenge oh yeah I mean
yeah you can I mean if you have a good
good platform where you can
um input that sort of information into
your your algorithm your your model your
agent you know whatever is
um creating those just-in-time prompts
you can do it at one example being we
spoke with Michael the study you
platform that is being developed by
um
the house of plattner Institute right
with stuff on it all so they have for
example there are platforms that are
being developed where you can
personalize the the
circumstance related factors and in even
at the at a more basic level in these
instances of what we have is if you have
a mobile app delivered intervention um
they can just like hit pause and then
they don't receive
a prompt or like they say hey I'm flying
and then you can you have that
information but then the person might
just be annoyed and just say like I'm on
a plane every day and then like that's
kind of that ends up being in a missing
beta so that's yeah
I'm not missing at randomly
and turn on their GPS
you know from from afar and the collect
data you don't don't I'm not
recommending to do that but yeah so that
would be yes
a little cluster two by like one right
yeah
also these are means I I think there are
a few there are some individuals who
were active on some days
I don't know if this was partly because
let's see so the bulk of the data
collection happened last year
um we started in the spring of 2021
so one could potentially argue maybe
they were still under the effect of um
of covid right so some of them were
inactive but then it was there was a lot
of summertime data collection so I could
one could encounter argue and say well
if it's summer you know by then you know
people are more in the summer we know
that people are more likely to have
accumulate more steps compared to let's
say winter months so that that's
something that would um combat that so
yeah so that would be it or maybe this
is just an overall sanitary sample
yeah
it would be interesting to know the
employment status so for employment I
had about four
the
if we have 50 full-time about 30
part-time
and then we had I think maybe 20 or
something like either not unemployed
either because like they're retired or
their student or or so forth but across
the the Clusters that it was pretty even
evenly distributor I think because by
now even people's work schedules that
you know some work from home and then
some people are active and then even if
you're working in an office you're
sitting all day long so I think that
kind of there's you know so much
variance even within the categories
in the styles of organism that could be
but I in on the other hand when you
think of the general you know U.S
population sedentary behavior is you
know the prevalence of sanitary here is
very very high so maybe it's not that
surprising so
that's yeah so I guess
mind your steps
all right one last question
is how you make sure that your
standpoint you collect is representative
of the target group that you would
Target at like would you apply some
questionnaire or a survey about their
lifestyle like were they in training
with a smoke or are they reporting
person or that person like that impact
their like sleep apology and stuff
well so I feel like you asked me two
questions in one question so first what
a part was how do I make sure that my
sample is representative of the
population
in terms of the population we're
interested in black and latinx sexual
and gender minority adults and we had
ultimately 100 I mean we did hit those
criteria we did enroll from across the
United States I think the bias here
would be of course there's of course the
selection bias because right like it's
all the research is based on consent
like you can have on consented
individual parts so like maybe you can
say like by way of choosing to be in
this study there might have been some
factors that make them you know
different than the rest of the
population but we didn't stratify based
on I mean the supply of the study so we
didn't stratify by let's get one at
least one person from each state like
that that we didn't do
um in terms of Baseline factors like
smoking and so forth Etc so those are
not some like in those cases we're not
so worried about the representation
because the the minority stress model it
doesn't necessarily make statements
about those factors like these
individuals smoke or so that was
anything but but we did collect
information on those
um like drinking alcohol consumption and
smoking Etc so yeah we do have those
data we we haven't um I'm gonna say we
didn't we didn't collect date on it
folks big round of applause for Apec
we all run away though just a few quick
um last announcements epec talked about
the stand Workshop that's something
we've done every year separate last year
last year in the pandemic just sort of
wore down what you want to try to do
again this summer at some point we have
a stand Workshop it's three days taught
by Jonah gabri sometimes Michael
Bettencourt sometimes other members of
the team Andrew Gelman shows up for a
little bit of it sometimes I know you've
been to the the workshop you've been
there it's a really great Workshop
um I've learned a lot from that we've
been doing it for like seven years and I
keep learning more new stuff every every
year so it's a good Workshop we'll make
an announcement about that once we get
our act together on that also workshops
with the New York art conference coming
up in July there's going to be workshops
there from like Max [ __ ] and Rob Hindman
if you don't know who they are Mexican
wrote tidy models and carrot Rob Hyman
wrote forecast and Fable and there's
gonna be lots of other workshops as well
those are just the ones that are top of
mind
um so remember there's a bunch of
conferences coming up the next few
months like I said New York R the uh
Tampa data the D4 data conference the
data Council conference in Austin you'll
get emails about all those with discount
codes whatever the conferences provide
we have a March speaker lined up but we
need a February speaker so someone from
this group in the person or virtual is
going to be our February speaker right
one more round of applause repack thank
you very much
goodbye see you next time